um good evening everybody and welcome to
this evening's meeting of planning and
development management committee just by
way of introduction my name is aiden
williams and i'm the chair of the
committee also present this evening at
the committee vice chair councillor ben
hartley officers from the council's
planning service legal and democratic
services local highway authority as well
as the elected councillors who make up
the voting members of the committee
before we continue i should just advise
um for everyone's attention that this
meeting has been live streamed and
recorded
and before turning to the applications
for the development this evening i'll
just explain for the benefit of anybody
watching the process that is undertaken
by committee this evening there's a
number of planning applications which
need to be determined each application
will receive a brief introduction from
an officer of the council's planning
service and they will provide a
recommendation as to how they feel
committee members should vote there will
then be the opportunity for
representations from approved community
groups representatives and members of
the public following this a discussion
will be held by members of the planning
committee
members will discuss the merits of each
application utilizing their local
knowledge they should explain whether
they are minded to support or oppose
officer recommendation and should
approach
the devote this evening with an open
mind in so doing they should explicitly
justify their decision by making clear
reference to planning grounds and
recognized planning policies and
frameworks
members are free during the discussion
to ask officers for guidance or
clarification members can propose a
motion to support or refuse officer
recommendation if the motion is
supported by a second member a vote will
be held and the outcome determined by
majority decision
now just turning to the agenda this
evening item number one is attendances
and we've received apologies from
councillors akanola and win stanley
i don't think any of that no
um item number two is declarations of
interest are there any members um the
council are talking
okay thank you thank you for that any
other um
council welcome uh i'm on the board at
timberlee sports club which i suppose
could be regarded as
in the same
uh
field nearby
okay thank you i can't see any of the
members indicating um item number three
is minutes the minutes of the previous
meeting have been circulated
uh members happy to counselor hartley's
proposing that we accept those comes the
morgan seconded
oh there you go
sorry yeah um there's a um error in the
minutes um it says that i declared a
personal interest i actually declared a
lot of personal interest in the
um in the same way that council bunting
um did so if that could be amended that
would be grateful
that that's fine yeah
okay members happy to accept those
with that amendment
um question number item number four is
questions for members of the public we
haven't received any to my knowledge
item number five is the additional
information report which has been
circulated to members via email earlier
today and there's paper copies available
this evening as well and then item
number six is applications for
permissions to develop
um the first application that we will
consider this evening is 105 315 15
sunderly drive in hail which can be
found on page 45 of the committee report
and before we hear from speakers
the application is going to be
introduced by ms
milner thank you chair so the first
application for members this evening
relates to 15 sunderly drive in hail a
two-story semi-detached property
commissioner saw the direction of a
two-story side extension and a part
single part two story rear extension the
application was deferred for amendments
at the january planning committee that
feral allowed and for amendments to take
place to jews reduce the depth and
massing of the overall scheme
and the india plans submitted reduced
the depth of the rear extension by 0.7
meters from a 4.2 projection to a 3.5
projection at both single and two-story
level
in addition we have amendments to the
fenestration on the rear elevation
they've removed one window from the rear
elevation of the of the extension and
also changed the size of some of the
other windows um
these amendments have been reconsorted
on um
in terms of the massing the fenestration
came in late but the overall massing was
reconsorted on and we've received no
objections to these changes
so therefore subject to
the conditions outlined in the deferral
report which now obscure includes an
obscure glazing condition we do
recommend approval thank you
thank you ms milner um there are two
speakers speaking to this application
speaker against is joe ashford who's
provided a statement which will be read
out by
ms kohli
thank you chair
this is a statement from joash raf and
kamal khan of 11a sanderly drive we are
not planning to attend tomorrow's
meeting but please could our email be
passed on to the committee following on
from last month's meeting we are
delighted to report that we have had
positive discussions with the architect
and the new owner of 15 sandalay drive
faye
they have been receptive to our comments
and appreciative of how others have
extended their properties we are pleased
that they have reconsidered the local
guidance and our comments and reduced
the extension size the extension now
extends to 3.5 metres only no further
than any other extension on nearby
semi-detached properties and also has a
width of 4.84 metres which again is
comparable to similar approved projects
in our neighborhood
through this process fae has been
welcomed into our community and we're
looking forward to being neighbours
thank you chair
thank you ms kowali um speaking in favor
of the application is sam tao
hi mrtal thank you for joining us um if
you just approach
the microphone if you can just make sure
it's on it should illuminate on the
button and at the end of the microphone
okay
i've got three minutes to speak if you
want to say apart from the fact that you
know evening and good to see you all and
i can't say um thank you enough uh for
the opportunity for us to engage with uh
the neighboring properties i think
that's a
that's a fantastic idea and we
ultimately created a win-win situation
uh to all and you know i couldn't say
thank you enough for the opportunity to
defer the application so um yeah are you
the rest of my time thank you
thank you thank you mr tower um council
and minister indicating like to speak
i just want to say this this is a great
example actually of uh you know the
process working where you know something
was a bit was too big and then gone back
and neighbors have worked together to
come up with something that's
that's acceptable to both so well done
and thank you very much i propose that
we um that we grant this application
thank you
thank you any of the members that
counsel bunting
thank you chairman yes i agree with
council administ i was one of those last
time we spoke
and suggested that although i wasn't
happy with the previous application we
weren't very far away from uh from an
acceptable solution
we got with referral
the process has worked and i'm more than
happy to uh second the proposal just
made thank you chairman
thank you are there any other members
looking to speak
no
counselor harley
thank you chair i think the main concern
last time was around the projection of
the extension at
first floor to the to the rear
uh which was quite which was quite long
that's been reduced i have to stay
looking at the
plans and views i still think it's quite
large but i think the statement we've
just heard from the neighbors quite
quite useful uh no one seems to take
objection to it although that's not
decisive for us um
but the the
projection still seems to be
uh contrary to spd4 but obviously that
is only guidance and
given the efforts the applicants made
i'm happy to to also approve the
application thank you
thank you um i i just i don't think
there's much uppercase for protracted
debate on this so um i just echo what um
other members have said that i'm very
pleased that committees had a well found
a way to um
find a satisfactory uh
solution and outcome to
uh this application for parties involved
and and i i think councillor young you
felt similarly and thank you for the the
role you played in um advocating and
trying to
mediate between those parties um so with
that well it has been proposed in a
second did the um
permission be granted in line with
officer recommendation those in favor of
that motion can indicate
okay that application is unanimously
approved
and we'll now turn to application
105.445.12
rossett avenue in temporally which can
be found on page 63 of the committee
report before we hear from speakers the
application is going to be introduced by
ms milner
thank you chair so
the application for us now is um
12 foster avenue a two-story
semi-detached property on rossett avenue
planning permission is sought for a
two-story side and a part single part
two-story rear extension
and the application is before
members of the discretion of the head of
planning
four objections have been received
regarding the scale of the proposal and
the impact this would have visual
appearance and amenity to surrounding
neighbours
amendments were secured through the
application process
and to reduce the scale of the
application
and
that was the report and put forward in
the committee report
following this further amendments were
submitted yesterday to
further reduce the scale of the result
and that is detailed in the additional
information report and is presented on
your screens now
and officers do again recognize this is
a large extension it wraps around the
side and rear of the building
projects four meters to the rear at
ground
and
and 3.2 at first um
there is specific reasons why we
consider this to be acceptable and
extensions to the neighboring properties
and distance to the rear boundary so it
does comply
with our guidance
therefore
taking it on balance
we feel that it does comply and it is
recommended for
approval subject to the conditions
within the report thank you
thank you ms milner and there are two
speakers speaking against the
supplication
robin raymond and councillor brophy have
you decided you'd like to speak first
do you know
mr aim thank you for joining us if you
can just make sure the microphone's on
and you've got three minutes to speak if
you run over time i'll just politely ask
that you wrap up your contribution thank
you
you
you
you
thank you mr raymond um
councillor brophy if you'd like to and
just sit before the microphone you've
got five minutes to speak if you do run
over time i'll
politely ask that you wrap up your
contribution thank you
and
oppressive and harmful visual aesthetics
we were led to believe that there will
be some substantial amendments from the
agents however it does turn out that
these amendments are tiny and
insignificant we note the ones that have
been received today but they're still
not to the degree the residents will be
happy with
the neighbors at number 14 will be
overshadowed by a two-story wall that
will be entering light downstairs and
upstairs and it will cast a shadow on
large parts of their back garden
and the impact of this is made
considerably worse by the 40 degree
offset has just been mentioned by the
resident that spoke
the neighbors at number 10 will be
affected by an unacceptable loss of
light into their rear lounge windows and
loss of visual immunity
and the extension at number 12 will be
overbearing and cast shadow onto their
patio and it will not line up with their
modest existing extension
so the residents of both sides would be
happy if their new neighbour planned an
extension that was in line and in
keeping with the others that were
already in the area
the proposed extensions will more than
double the original footprint and it
won't harmonize with other residential
developments in this vicinity of timpani
and has been mentioned it will set an
unfortunate precedent that could ruin
the character and nature of this area
so the huge two-story wall at the side
of the alleyway it will also make this
passageway very dark and naturally
neighbours are concerned about an
increase in antisocial behavior i think
this is something the committee should
note because i have heard of instances
of serious antisocial behavior attended
by the police in this area near the
passageway
and the wall if you can imagine will
kind of lead to a darkness descending on
that passageway
so the residents are
quite incredulous that this application
has now been recommended for approval
and it's extraordinary most
disappointing to the immediate residents
on all sides
so in summary
this development is overbearing and
oppressive
number 10 would suffer extreme loss of
light and the huge wall on the number 14
sign would be oppressive
we didn't feel that the planning officer
gave enough consideration and necessary
weight to the layout of the site
especially the setback 40 degree angle
frontage of number 14 in relation to
that of number 12.
this is not the case of side by side but
one property number 14 set back and turn
to face the applicant of number 12.
also the application it's not in keeping
with other extensions in the area which
would set a precedent for future
applications
anyone can build anything which is not
what we'd like for this area
and it will create this huge prison-like
wall of a very dark alleyway encouraging
anti-social behavior
this massive and overbearing extension
would lead to a loss of light and
significant loss of amenity
i'm also aware that there are a number
of councillors on this planning
committee that have been to visit and
look at the site and i do hope that the
committee listened to those councillors
who have been to visit the site and note
the impressions of those who've actually
seen it for themselves
and i do hope the planning committee
councils will listen to the neighbors
views and on balance
reject these plans or can at least
considerably scale them down because
they are an overbearing and
inappropriate development for the area
thank you
thank you councillor and speaking in
favor of the application is santo
um thank you for joining us uh again if
you've got three minutes to speak if
you're on overtime i'll just politely
ask that you've already
just asked for ps
134
to be displayed on the screen if
possible please
[Music]
is that elevations floor plans no it's
the is the floor plan for the existing
and the proposed side by side
for the first floor
okay
not this one
it's one three four
um
sorry about this
i do have a copy here if you want to i
mean if you can see it
what was the number 134 ps134
thank you
right should i start yeah so first of
all i just want to say thank you for uh
councillor brophy uh to give us the
opportunity to meet with the opposing
neighbors on site
to discuss
their concern
i
again you know taking the cue from the
from number 15 sandy lee we felt that
that was the right approach to do
we have listened to the concern and we
have reduced the scale of this
development
considerably
if i can just quickly explain the
real extension a single-story
re-extension
of the property
has been scaled back from the if you can
see the
um on the the plant on the left hand
side you can see the curve conservatory
uh that was the existing uh for those of
you who's been on site you may not see
it because it's been demolished since
but that was the existing
conservatory
footprints and that has now been reduced
from 4.8 meters to 4 meters so we
actually have made a net loss of
areas at the back of the property
precisely
to uh to create a harmonizing
sustainable development
for the adjacent neighbor number 10.
as per number 14
again we have
heard you know listen to the concern
but if i can just put this into context
if you look at the plan on the left hand
side which is the existing
first floor
layout
the
site extension has already existed in
large
uh what we are trying to do is to
slightly enlarge it uh by its width and
also its depth we are we are
creating a
one meter
um
more uh
as his death and obviously we are
widening it now if i can also point out
that uh number 14 which is on the other
side of the alleyway
and the relationship between number 14
and number 10 if i can just use this
graph on my laptop as
a guidance
i know it's difficult to see but
this is number 14 and this is number 12
our property the two property diverges
on more than 45 degrees at its rear
so the yes of course there will be an
impact
but i would argue on two points number
one the impact is
reduced because of the divergence of the
two properties at the rear and number
two they
that the the structure on the side of
the property which is two stories has
already been largely existed we are not
bringing a new
psy extension that span 11 meters at all
so i hope that uh you know
the chair and the committee members will
take this into account and and to to
appreciate the context as well uh and
come to your favorite welcome thank you
thank you mr tower um council minister
indicating
thank you chair
um
i went and visited well i know the area
very well because it's in within my ward
and i've walked down that alleyway a
number of times cut through from
readings road to rossett
um
i've
i went to see it
in terms of and actually neighbours were
very kind both sides allowed me to go in
their back garden to see
um the impact on them and to actually
see it for myself
i think
the the the to me
the issues for each of them is slightly
different
but i think that it is ultimately
too big
and i think there's a massing problem
and the massing massive there's a huge
massing problem
on the um
not adjoining side if you will the one
by the alleyway
um because that's where you've got
basically practically a blank wall now i
know it's stepped in slightly it's by
one brick i mean it's tiny
um
you can see the pictures but uh you know
this is one brick so it's 15 centimeters
and then we've got
to me it's when you just if you stand at
the patio doors of number 10
you're just not going to get the light
and it's going to land up in darkness
and you've got big patio doors that we
should you know you should get light
through and you won't i don't think
you're going to get light
i'm i'm afraid i'm on this i don't agree
with the offices i don't think this is
an acceptable um application as it is i
would like it to be if i don't know
whether um anyone's up for deferring it
to
um a further committee where something
more sensible can come forward
and more discussion can be had between
neighbors like we had with sanderly
to get to come up with something because
i think i can understand people wanting
to i understand wanting to extend
i understand wanting more more living
space but
i don't think this is the this is the
answer i don't think it's the way
it's not it's not a fair i think on on
on neighboring properties to have either
loss of light
or basically immunity and we're talking
about there's an alleyway
and that goes there's a right of way for
people to walk
and so i'm going to be proposing that we
either i'd like to defer it if we can if
not then uh to refuse the application
thank you
perhaps if we hear from other members
you can
determine a motion after that and
counselor thomas please
thank you sir i visited the site and had
a good look around
there was nobody in the property but i
could gain access to the back garden i
went and had a look down there
to my mind
the massing and the size of the project
is
terrible
street scene would be massively affected
number 10 the conservatory the extension
goes two meters past their conservatory
a slightly bigger height
um from what i could tell which would
have
impairment on
their immunity there number 14
the visual immunity look out the side of
their houses straight onto a flat brick
wall
the footpath the light issue would be
absolutely
terrible and that's a school footpath
notwithstanding the fact that they would
need to apply for the footpath to be
closed
um
so basically i would propose that it is
refused on overbearing street scene
and visual impairment of immunity for
number 14 and number 10. thank you chair
thank you councillor morgan
thank you chair um
it's probably some of your advice i mean
i've never i've been on this committee
nearly three years and i've never seen
quite so many
an amendment this late in the day um i
mean it's it's not a small amendment by
any any any um
um
it's quite significant amendment to what
the original plans were submitted
yesterday i'm sure most of us just
went
days ago if not we over a week ago and i
mean i i
i struggle to be able to judge on those
plans that i i mean i imagine for the
planning department as well reviewing
the amended plans with such a short
period is probably quite tight so i'm i
have to be honest i'm really minded to
the second council minister's proposal
to defer this because i don't honestly
think i think it's reasonable to expect
members to decide on something which to
be honest with you i saw 15 minutes
before this meeting um because i've been
at work all day and so i don't know what
your view on that and other members
would be
thank you and encounter the bunting
yes thank you chairman i'm
more than happy to agree with
councillors minister thomas i visited
the site and the council both he
suggested
mentioned councils visiting i'm sure we
all have visited canceled both at least
i i hope we have
um
and i had a look at the site like
councillor thomas uh there was nobody in
when i i looked like to be like the site
was an occupied so i took the
opportunities to be able to look at the
garden uh
the display you know the side of the
access is was open
um it is
unfortunately i say this is definitely
too large for the site um
i know we have a divergence but this is
ironically one of those cases where
actually makes it worse
it's you normally you'd think okay
there's a greater space uh between the
two and but given the orientation of 14
it yeah it would be better if it was
side by side um it would be you know but
even so i i still can't see and i take
council morgan's point that's you know
this is some late and it changes but
uh and like council morgan i've been at
work all day i didn't get the luxury of
[ __ ] i'm saturn and reading through
council emails
um
so yes i accept his point that is a bit
late in the day to start making a large
scale change although even with the
changes as far as i can see from what
i've read it and seen them on the
screens it
is still too large uh you know over
development visual immunity
overshadowing
uh and
yes and also i'm concerned i say
regarding as council thomas also points
out the effect on that um on that
passageway uh
i'm not 100 sure i know why last time i
spoke and i said that
uh deferral might be a
good option about when that was offered
i thought it was a good idea this one i
think perhaps is but maybe
too much to deal with via deferral
and possibly refuse obviously the
applicant can resubmit with them any
plans later on
uh whether
i mean if members think that deferral is
the best way to go
i'll i'll i'll accept that but uh i
think perhaps is i think this give it
given the nature of this application i
think we're pushing it in terms of
back in such a short period of time um
might need a little bit more uh amending
than the than the sandal he wanted uh to
to
you know the sandy lee one i said we
weren't that far away uh on this one i
think with a substantial distance away
so i'm more than happy to support uh the
proposal of refusal which has already
been
uh put forward by council minister
thomas uh however i'm i will go along
with deferral if that's what the
committee feels thank you chairman
thank you and councillor chalking
with um
all the other councils have said uh
such i will go further and say and agree
with councillor bunsing and say i don't
actually think deferral is the right
option here i think there's too much to
you have to go back to the basics back
to the beginning here and i think
um
[Music]
we should be minded to refuse this and
the applicants should go back and have a
look at it for me the biggest problem
looking at the plans is one of the
residential immunity i cannot see how
on an entire for the future occupiers of
this property how it's going to be a
nice property to live and it's it looks
too dark to me there's not enough light
um
i just on the pure
um architectural
standpoint the kitchen design is the
wrong way around to me the right the
light is coming from the other side of
the building not from the side that
they've put the skylights in so it
doesn't work
um for me just looking at the plans but
i do think they need to go back to the
drawing board on this one
so our second
thank you um councillor hartley
thank you chair yeah i i mean i've
written some comments down here but i do
i think i take on board councillor
morgan's point actually that it's
it's quite difficult you know uh 10 15
minutes before the meeting to sort of
reassess those views having been looked
at the property already and there are
and there are some significant changes
you know as councilor morgan said
because the comments are harder around
the um
the the offset the angle means number 14
we'll be looking at this big extension
but but the setback has been increased
so
that that might change that although i
don't i don't think significantly enough
uh likewise i think number 14 one of the
uh things that the speaker mentioned was
they'll be looking at a two-story blank
brick wall and i think a window's been
put in but it is only a small one but
you know i haven't you know haven't
considered the the impacts of that of
that fully i don't i don't think the
impact upon number 10 uh
it is as great um
the street scene when i looked at it
front on i thought well there's probably
not going to be much impact on the
street scene but
i think i think the point is you come
around the bend in the road you would
you would sort of see it but again the
setback's been reduced so would it would
it be as significant um
the design at the back is a is a real
mess it's every conceivable sort of roof
form you could you could cram into it
i'm afraid but you know the impact of
that is it's probably limited giving it
given it's hidden i um
so i i think it's too big uh and i and i
um i would also
want us to reject it um
i don't think we should defer i think
i'm uneasy about
deferral when i could understand the
point of deferring an item if a small
change would make a
an unacceptable application acceptable
but otherwise if we're deferring just to
give the applicant another chance to put
in an acceptable application well
we reject applications all the time
because what's proposed is too big so i
do think we need to be really careful
about deferring and
giving the applicant a chance to make
major changes to make the application
acceptable um because we reject
countless applications and the applicant
then has to go through the delay and the
cost of submitting a new one so i would
um agree with um councillor bunting and
others have said i think i would reject
this and i wouldn't i wouldn't want us
to defer the item thank you
thank you councillor hassan thank you
chair uh i'm fully agreed with the
majority of my
counselors and colleagues have said
i think we should reject it instead of
wasting time and energy of the
officers are not concerned
there is no point of deferred and then
coming back again with no amendments at
all and it's the wasting of time and
energy and money
i'm agree with my voice chair as well
thank you
thank you um
i think
uh that we have had a discussion that's
touched on a number of issues with this
application
um
what i would say is that what's before
this is a policy compliant proposed
development if members aren't happy with
it i think the right thing to do
probably would be to refuse the
application because i think
deferring it after
the applicant already having made
amendments that are quite significant
i'm not sure that it would necessarily
accomplish enough to satisfy members
if you're if you're happy with that
cancel a minute
i'd be happy with the refusal i mean i i
was i was hoping it'd be retrievable but
i i don't think it's retrievable either
in my opinion i think that you know the
amendments if you look at the the
history you know on the planning portal
the history of it they are they've all
been like tiny so i i i'm happy with the
refusal thank you
thank you santa and it has as i
understand i've ever recorded this
correctly been proposed by councillor
thomas and seconded by councillor bunton
that the application be refused
minister thomas about we'll take that
then um i think i i heard from um
council the minis
i think your face contribution expressed
that you thought that there was a
massing problem and counselor joking um
expressed that he felt that that would
have a unacceptable impact on
residential immunity other reasons that
other members want to try and express
as to why
cancer the minis and there's also so
number 14 i think you've got a loss of
amenity i think you've also got a lot of
meaning to number 10 and there's also
the massing problem um and that's
uh for the for more for number 14 the
massing problem
um but i think i don't know whether it's
a lot of light falls into loss of
immunity i guess in it really
yep okay that's fine
okay counselor thomas did you want to
get just overbearing overshadowing as
well
[Music]
the reasons being designed and
immediately then okay
um just before we turn to that i just
want
um just before we do turn to that i just
want to thank the applicant for the work
that they did do to try and um
uh work with neighbors to reach a
satisfactory outcome i think just
unfortunately this instance it didn't
quite get there um
and
now with that it has been proposed and
seconded that the application be refused
contrary to
um officer recommendation if those
voting in support of that motion can
indicate now
okay i think that's anonymous the
application is refused
um we'll now turn to application one
zero double five two zero four chilton
drive in hale which can be found on page
73 of the committee report
before we hear from speaker's
application is going to be introduced by
ms milner
there we go
and
so this application relates to a
two-story detached property
on the west side of children drive in
it's
hail
all right um so if we
start this application again with an
introduction from ms milner
thank you chair so this application
relates to a two-story detached property
located on the west side of chilton
drive and hail plan information is sort
of for the direction of a
two-story side rear and front extension
essentially though it is all to the to
the side but because of the the
formation of the existing property we've
described it as frontside in maria
and
the application has been reported to
planning committee because more than six
objections have been received um
additionally the application was called
in if it were to be refused but that is
not the case it is um to be approved um
recommended for approval but with six
objections
um more than six objections eight
representations from different um
addresses were received in total
objections raised concerns about amenity
design highways and other matters
including the development used um as a
separate annex
following officer assessment and many
amendments were made including the
removal of a flat roofed roof extension
and also the um the massing was reduced
in scale and so that it complied with
the guidance within spd4 and also floor
plans were mended to show that the
extension
um
wasn't divided
was part of the house and not as a
separate annex
um
it's considered that whilst quite a
large extension it because of the
positioning on the site
and because of the conditions proposed
within the report it wouldn't have a
harmful impact on amenity
and specifically there are two
conditions relating to obscure glazing
to
ensure that two windows are obscure
glazed on installation and prevent
further windows
to be installed in the future on a
particular elevation that would avoid
harmful overlooking
therefore subject to the conditions we
do recommend approval thank you chair
thank you ms mona and there were two
speakers speaking against this
application i don't know um mr hall or
counselor young if you know who'd like
to speak first
mr hall
thank you for joining us mr hall
oh sorry
mr hall it's provided a statement as i
understand it which will be read out by
ms coley
thank you chairman
this is a joint statement from numbers
43 rivington road and 2 chilton drive we
wish to object to the proposal for
chilton drive
this application has changed on multiple
occasions making adequate comment
incredibly challenging indeed the final
plans were submitted and accepted on the
planning portal after the expiry date of
the 23rd december 2021 effectively
making all previous representations an
argument against superseded documents
in addition we would like to point out
the following the application represents
a sizable increase of almost 70 to the
existing property in context 100 would
be a duplicate house this huge
percentage increase gives a gross
additional internal floor area of more
than 90 square meters across three
floors ground first and loft space
if this application was to be granted it
would set a precedent encouraging
further people to build what is in
effect a new dwelling comparable or
indeed larger than many hail b street
properties in tight garden spaces
the obviously devastating impact on
neighbouring properties has been one of
the driving reasons so many local people
are against this application
currently the unique orientation spacing
and design of two children drive 43
rivington road and four children drive
complement each other perfectly in terms
of massing sunlight and privacy
this long-standing spacious relationship
would be significantly harmed if a
two-story extension was to be granted
giving way to a terracing effect as the
three buildings closed in on one another
in addition surely this application
fails when tested against multiple
clauses from spd4 including 2.31 a scale
and proportion 2.72
glimpsed greenery between buildings
2.8.1 gaps between buildings 2.14.2
overbearing impact on neighbouring
immunity and 2.17.1
sense of enclosure
we are objected to the size scale and
proximity of the development to the
neighbouring properties especially the
tunnel effect created between number two
and number four chilton
the size of the development will block
sunlight from our homes and gardens and
block out glimpse views of greenery from
both from homes in the streets
destroying the current open and spacious
street scene
we have invited councillors to our
property and private rear garden to feel
the existing openness and spaciousness
that we've enjoyed for many years thanks
thank you to those that visited spoke to
us and listened to our point of view on
this development to be clear we have no
objection to a single story extension
that would still add significant floor
area to the property thank you
thank you um councillor young are you
speaking against this application as
well
oh apologies yeah
right
thank you mr miller would you like to
speak in favor got three minutes to
speak thank you uh this is an
application to extend for chilton drive
it is not an application to make a
detached house into a pair of
semi-touched houses
since there was a misconception from
objectors that a separate property was
being designed i updated an earlier
application drawing to exactly match the
external form and elevations issued by
the planners for consultation
the internal arrangement of a dwelling
is not a planning matter
and so the proposal is no different from
the consultation drawings in planning
terms
there is no often version
additionally this was this highly
insulated passivhaus style extension was
to be a potential annex for elderly
relatives and later to be combined back
into the original house
now that doctor and mrs panton are
expecting their fourth child this needed
to change
however the intention is still to erect
the extension and fully complete it
without affecting their use of the
existing home before knocking through
my original proposal for a larger
dwelling than the current proposal but
the applicant preferred it to be only
sufficient for their purposes so the
design was reduced in size
at this point on 21st july 2021 the
applicant went round to discuss the
proposal with both neighbours
during the planning process the
extension was further shrunk back from
the boundary to number two additionally
to comply with the daylighting
guidelines in sbd4 although i'd already
proven that the extension already comply
with national daylight standards econo
has been taken out of the kitchen and
study over
i'm not only an architect but a
chartered state
arbitrator an expert witness and i rely
on my reputation for impartiality
my lighting report reflects that
impartiality
43 ravington has windows to circulation
spaces and a window to the dining area
of an open plan kitchen overlooking four
chilton the latter two spaces have other
daylighting sources other than the
kitchen these spaces have no set
requirements for daylighting
the arrangement of detached houses in
the street is to have either an integral
garage with a small space before the
boundary or a drive to one side of the
property no detached house including two
children have drives to both sides of
the property
the proposal for number four is no
different
in my view four children is the ugliest
house on chilton drive itself as it
currently stands it is located next to
two children a contemporary new build
from 1992 the flat roofed house on the
corner of chilton drive and hale road is
a recent dwelling that does not conform
to the character of the area
the spatial requirements of sbd4
are also more than complied with the gap
at the front of the property to the
boundary to two children is 1.5 metres
or just over 1.5 meters or 5 feet
there is no change in the distance
between two children sorry four children
and 43 riggington
the proposal prevents current
overlooking of the garden of two
children from the existing kitchen the
new first floor window facing 43
rivington is to be obscured i'm sure
that the extended dwelling will be an
asset to the street scene
thank you very much
thank you mr miller
thank you councillor young you have five
minutes to speak if you do one over time
i'll just ask that you wrap up your
contribution
when doctor and mrs panton bought the
four four-bedroomed house for chilton
drive in 2018
they saw the potential to extend the
property and to improve the seat the
street scene due to the current odd
appearance of the property from chilton
drive
there are no windows and only a front
door opening onto the road it is really
just half a house as can be seen on the
existing elevation
and there's no other house in the road
quite like this
the pantins want a house that fits into
the street scene and improves the look
of the house and the look of the street
the panties of three children
two boys aged seven and nine and a
four-year-old girl
mrs panton is expecting another child in
june
the family are already badly short of
space
their washing machine is located in the
garage and the pipeworks of the garage
regularly freezes in the winter
their daughter's bedroom is 1.7 by 2.7
meters
and won't easily fit a standard single
bed let alone an adult bed presently she
sleeps in the child's cot
and the larger room is a necessity as is
a fifth bedroom to accommodate the new
arrival
dr pantin who is a respiratory
consultant at withenshaw badly needs a
study where he can work at home
undisturbed
the proposed extension will deliver a
house with plenty of space
to accommodate this growing family
it will sit happily in the street
particularly as it is proposed that the
existing brickwork facing the extension
will be taken down cleaned and reused in
the front facade and laid in lime water
existing roof tiles will also be reused
i'm told that before the plans for the
extension was submitted
the neighbors at two chilton drive and
43 rivington road were contacted and mrs
panton sat down with each of them to
explain the proposed plans and no
concerns were raised other than the
rivington road resident mentioning that
the extension would block his view of
the trees in the cemetery approximately
100 meters away
about three weeks later having heard
nothing more from the neighbors the
planning application was submitted
as you have heard from keith miller
care was taken to ensure that these two
houses were not badly overlooked
he undertook a daylight study on the
effect of a proposal on daylight
striking the face of the rear elevation
of the property
which showed that the proposal reduced
the daylighting by under 1.7
this would not have been noticeable
since the overshadowing reduces the
daylighting by less than 27
and it was agreed with the planning
officer that to fully comply with the
rule of thumb guidance given in spd4
that a corner was cut out of the kitchen
and study
the windows were arranged so that no
window directly overlooks number two
chilton drive and the window to the
study is obscured as is also the case
with the first floor windows facing
number two
chilton drive
there's a minor loss of sunlight to the
lawn of number two chilton drive but
this does not breach the building
research establishment published
guidance
there was a misconception among the
neighbors that the panthens are not
actually enlarging their house
but are building what will amount to a
separate dwelling
i have queried this and have been
assured that this is absolutely not and
never was the case
the pantings love where they live which
is convenient for the children's school
local amenities and the extended family
but they do need the proposed five
bedrooms an extra living space to
accommodate their growing family
i would like to repeat what i said in my
original letter of support sent on the
20th of october
that i think that the finished extension
will fit well into the street
and i urge you to agree with the
officer's recommendation
and approve this application
thank you for letting me speak
thank you councillor young um councillor
bunting indicating
thank you chairman um
i have no objection
to this application i think it's a good
design i think it will fit well within
the street scene in fact as has been
pointed out
i think it will improve what is perhaps
at the moment a slightly anomalous
design uh the so-called half house that
was referred to previously i think it
would look uh make significant
improvements on that and and be a good
zone when it's done
uh i think this is also a good example
of uh where applicants has worked well
with
with officers to improve the uh original
submission indeed uh that's outlined in
the report that uh that the changes have
been made including to the floor plan
something to demonstrate to all concerns
should it need demonstrating that this
is not a separate dwelling i mean a
separate drawing would require a
different application to this
uh i don't think there are any arguments
i've been through the fairly extensive
list of objections and listed
and i can't say that i i i can't see
anything in there that would lead to a
substantial harm to anyone else in fact
uh as i say if anything this will
improve the improve the street scene
significantly i also can't see any
particular harm that's gonna cause to
anyone uh
given those those points chairman i'm
more than happy to propose that we
accept officer recommendation
and grant what is a perfectly reasonable
application thank you german thank you
um councillor dagner
hi um
unfortunately i disagree with councillor
bunting um having spent some time
standing in the garden of
number
sorry number two children drive
i i think it will have a massive impact
on their
well-being and happiness i don't see how
um anybody would wish to live um
next door to us two-story blank wall
um and looking back to the previous
application where that blank wall was
considered um
difficult to live with across a public
footpath i think that would be even more
difficult to live with when it is
literally um
1.5 metres behind the hedge and actually
having stood in the garden and looked at
the
garden room in the on the other side of
the of the garden
in the property on the other side and
seeing the blockage that that as a small
single story building makes um to be
honest the thought of a two-story
extension
so close to the house and so close to
the garden really did seem quite
overwhelming
um i have to say council lung does know
does the applicants no favor when she
suggests that five children cannot be
brought up comfortably in a four-bedroom
house and there are many residents in
trafford who would be able to offer
advice that would save the residents a
considerable amount of money and the
neighbors a lot of stress if they care
to take it however they are within their
rights to apply for this personally i
think it's overbearing i think it's
unfair to the neighbours um i don't
agree that the house as it is is
particularly ugly is what it is it's of
its time it's it's um
it's appropriate architectural at moment
i don't see that a single story
extension
would make any difference possibly with
a double story at some point but i do
think that blank wall
of two stories 1.5 meters from from next
door is unfair to them
um i'm sure it's within the planning
regulations but i personally think the
fact that the overshadowing only affects
a utility room and a bathroom doesn't
mean you know
potentially going forward as council
young mentioned people might like a
study that there is potential for those
rooms to be changed into any other
facility within the house
counselor bunting please feel free to
respond audibly it would be really
helpful because i know you have a lot of
experience that i don't have on this on
this committee
um
i also felt that it was unfair on the
residents at number 43
although it suggested that their
conservatory will offer them adequate
light
personally
unless it's an extremely super
conservatory i would have considered
that to be a life limited structure and
that potentially in the future that
conservatory will not be there and that
the light will be inadequate going into
the kitchen now i appreciate with my as
i've mentioned lack of experience on the
committee my points might not be
recognized within the planning
regulations but i did feel having stood
there with the residents uh the
neighbours yesterday
um
that it was fair that someone should
speak up on their behalf it is quite an
overwhelming extension
thank you thank you um councillor morgan
thank you chair um
boy this is a big um
development on on on the house um i'm
gonna go through some of the like
there's been a lot of objections raised
so i'm not gonna mention all of them um
so first on the light um i understand
the
to your immediate neighbors concerns but
i'm not quite sure number two is that
affected a number 43 rivington i think
is given the directions of the buildings
i don't think is affected enough to to
refuse it um 43 i understand about them
losing the view of the trees but i think
we've proved other applications with
where someone loses a small access some
trees before and number two about the
brick wall
already has a brick wall when they when
they bought it parkings and highways i
think there's any evidence to and um to
impose on on that those grounds and i'm
glad then the
updated commentary they've raised that
um members of this committee have
visited it i'm sure most of us have and
i i have visited and was in the garden
just last night
um
the one thing and it's something
counselor dagnant should raise and i i
i will listen i'm not i'm not going to
make a decision to tell you in other
members is um overbearing and massing um
and spd4
does mention that it should reflect an
extension reflect the character and
scale of the original dwelling and i
don't think anyone on this committee
could say it reflects the scale of the
original dwelling it's it's such a huge
um increase
um and
i i think it's an impact on number four
to rivington but i don't think i would
reject it on that grounds but i really
have concerns for number two um chilton
it will be a huge increase um to their
neighbour um and
i'm i'm just i'm just not sure whether
it's enough to reject it on planning
grounds um so i really would be
interested in what other members of the
committee
would say on that thank you
thank you councillor thomas
thank you joe i have to agree with uh
council dagnall on this
visited the house um
and the neighbors
uh and number two children
it's the
overshadowing overbearing massing on the
property and inconsiderate the rest of
the houses on the street
um
claustrophobic
overbearing in in terms of
there's going to be a
blank wall of two
stories
with roof
within
three meters of their front door
uh it will block all light or sunlight
other than when the sun is at
very high in the sky
uh
into their back garden
and
sorry just double check the notes it'd
be very enclosing
um
in the report
excuse me check
in report
um
4.3 meters coming out close to the
children road drive
lots of light and
when you come out your front door you
you look at all the other houses on that
street and there is a double double
driveway there may be a garage there is
a garage in the property at the moment
all one story all set back
all the driveways every single house on
chilton drive has double driveways
set apart from each other this one
doesn't
visual immunity overbearing
overshadowing similar to a previous one
or every application must have obviously
has to be on his own merits with regards
to 43
well
council young in her in her presentation
said
their knowledge that they will block the
view
and it's not just blocking the view it's
putting monolith in front of the view
on
on the property
and altering completely the street scene
i don't think the house is particularly
ugly at all i think the house is in line
with the remainder of chilton road so i
would propose that we reject the
officer's
recommendation and refuse
thanks chair
are you seconding
councillor buntings
no i'm proposing no no sorry sorry so
you're proposing refusal
i'm happy to second council
that helps
neighbors
um
i i um
of two minds hey i i it is a big
development um that is doubling the size
of the property almost doubling the size
of the property
it is gonna impact slightly on number
two uh on the garden um i
have read through this um lights the
sunlight report provided by mr miller i
don't think it's going to be as bad as
people fear but it is going to have an
impact
um
i don't see how
just reading through the
reports how it will stand up if it is
refused
because it does comply with
pretty much everything that so that's it
needs to
so i'm still on the fence on this um and
if anyone can convince me otherwise
either way please do um but i do have
just a point on um on the report itself
just to clarify something on point 33
um this is only probably of interest to
the officers
uh it talks about there there will be
sufficient space remaining on the
existing driveway for three number cars
in addition no on street parking
restrictions and carries on and it is
considered that the third car could
comfortably park on the highway does it
mean two number cars or and the third
car on the highway or three cars on the
drive and four on the highway
is that an error i just wanted to
clarify that
yeah
could be clearer and then i just do have
a question on this if i may um
i i know i i know what the um the point
is on that but i'm i'm not personally
happy and and i don't know the rules
around this or what the the um
parameters when the planning guidelines
are
i'm not happy with the concept that's
we say yes there's there's not quite
enough space in the drives but there's
plenty of space on the road
um and i don't know where we sit with
that if
you could help me understand
so what we have to look at is yes we
have spd3 and that provides the maximum
parking standards
um and so here we're saying there is
space on site
but it could park on site on on street
so we have those maximum standards and
then we have to look at the mppf and
what the mppf is quite clear on and
is that the impact on the highway
network has to be severe
so
byron's saying okay there is on-street
parking if there is on-street parking
available
there is no restrictions
and there isn't uh a known problem
then it we wouldn't we wouldn't win that
on appeal and we have lost on appeal and
what you're kind of saying there isn't
enough parking because the npp app is
severe
so that's how we have to take it
no problem
thank you just before we hear from other
speakers um mrs coley has asked her to
make the point of clarification
yeah certainly thank you chair i'd just
like to remind members there's no right
to a view under planning law so the fact
that the view might change over
somebody's garden is not something that
we can take into account um
i'm also hearing lots of um
almost like throwing the kitchen sink at
it um you have to identify harm and
specifically identify harm
just being slightly uncomfortable with
something and your starting point is the
development plan
and the snspd4 so your starting point is
that this is policy compliant because
officers have explained its policy
compliance that doesn't mean you can't
come to a different view to officers not
at all
but you have to go from the fact that
it's policy compliant and decide why in
this particular case
uh a a more stringent requirement should
be um imposed
um that that that's the test
so i just
want to make members aware of that
because to just say well we think it has
all these impacts the policy says it
won't have those impacts that's that's
the purpose of it
um so you have to explain why you think
in this particular case it it would
are you
make are you looking counselor to make a
specific point in response or are you
um that that people do to speak before
you have peace
that's the first one um counsel a minute
thank you chair so well
for me
like like um um as scholar said about
the rights of you isn't the thing that
we all like to have a nice view um so
the right to the view to the trees i
don't i i wasn't you know it's not a
thing that
one has a right the
parts that i was most concerned about
was
this i mean i can understand wanting the
extension i can understand especially
because we have more working from home a
growing family i can completely
understand that
and
the the issue i had was the size of it
and the impact it has on number two
number 43 i don't think it's going to be
that bad because it's quite
there's no space between them if that
makes sense whereas between number two
it goes so close to it so
i mean
my difficulty this is why i haven't i
haven't yet made my mind up is that we
have
and to me you know i'd be much more a
fan of something slightly smaller but an
extension on the last but um slightly
smaller not going out quite as far
but i understand that obviously we have
what's been put before us and what what
the applicant is asking is whether they
can have that
i can't i'm i'm trying to find a reason
to say no the only reason i can see is a
loss of immunity to number two
of light
um and that's and
i guess massing but i don't think it's
not
when when we have a comparison to the
previous application it's not it's
nowhere near
as bad as that that was you know
awful quite frankly so i don't think we
can compare the two
and they're completely different
situations i'm just trying to see
whether
i'm going to try and make my mind up
hopefully by the time i've heard
everybody else's contributions
sorry if i could
please don't compare
schemes to previous schemes on the
committee they're not they they
shouldn't be used as comparators and and
also he said you were trying to find a
reason for refusal you shouldn't be
trying to find a reason for refusal if
there are harms then that may lead to a
reason for refusal but to sort of search
around for one is not is not the job of
this committee
sorry it didn't mean i was trying to
search around for it i meant um to try
if they were what harms there are and
trying to see if they were obviously you
know
enough that one would question
you know
which way to get that that's what i
meant sorry
um
there are a number of the members
looking to be uh what i will do are call
members who haven't spoken first um
counselor maitland please
yeah just bri just briefly um i i've two
have stood in that garden um of um of
number two and um
it was just imagining this huge brick
wall with no windows in the tall having
that face in your day and i just thought
how overbearing that would be
and that was just the impression i got
and
some impact on immediately for number
two is your concern okay thank you
councillor council hartley
thank you chad i think um most of the
points i was going to make have been
covered actually by councillor uh
diagonal and and also what council
morgan said about the
the extension doesn't seem in scale with
the with the original dwelling so it so
it is a big extension um
i think yeah i think council of dakota
will cover everything i was going to say
about number two
and the impact from residential immunity
there i think for um
number 43 i think uh number five
rivington i think a few members have
said
um
there isn't much of an impact on on the
amenity there but actually i
thought there was so um
i was quite persuaded by the comments of
the the resident there mr howard i think
who i thought illustrated quite well how
the extension would would block out
light so i know
some members have have indicated about
loss of view but i don't think that's
the point i think it's that
when you look at
the extent of the uh extension it's it's
the impact on the light and i know in
the reporter
uh paragraph 24 it does address this and
says there are doors and
there's a conservatory to the rear which
um cancel the diagonal touch on this so
those rooms benefit from other sources
of light
um
but those uh
those doors in the conservatory are
north facing i think so they probably
don't get much
light through that route so so i was
concerned about the the impact on number
43 and the the light entering the
windows on the eastern elevation so i
think that's the only point that
uh hasn't been covered by by someone
else
so i'm i'm well i i i think
i think the impact is residential
immunity isn't it so i'm i'm not uh i'm
not 100 sure that's a enough to refuse
but i think what members have identified
is an impact on
uh residential immunity to number two
and number 43 in terms of
uh overshadowing and overbearing and
massing thank you
thank you i'm councillor hassan
i'm all right says you're just been
second to the
two phase thank you um councillor
bunting
thank you chairman just a couple of
points to make some of which have been
covered i'll skip over those obviously
things like the right to review i was
going to mention that's already been
clarified in terms of the size and the
fact that yes this is uh substantially
increased but if you look at say for
example
uh the size of this property even when
extended compared to other properties
sort of immediately next to and then
compare that to the size of the plot of
land on which they sit
then you can see that eventually you
will essentially
no difference if this were to go ahead
because uh if you look uh for example
we've mentioned number two and if you
look at the the the way that the
material in its plot compared to say for
example where number four does know and
the way that number four will do if
extended i don't think there is a
substantial difference there so to try
and argue that this is a a far too
bigger property to go within the plot of
land given the local situation and the
uh density within this area i think that
is a difficult point to make given
that's
given that situation so i'm comfortable
with the size of it i accept it's large
but i think given the peculiar
circumstances that's not going to be too
much of an issue in terms of the
overshadowing as people have been
talking about in terms of the impact
upon neighbours the only real impact i
can see is on number two i think number
43 is just not impacted at all
uh in terms of number two but then again
i would have thought impactor number two
was more severe from the opposite side
the 186 or that large white box and a
huge gallery like windows overlooked
from that side uh so the impact on on in
terms of overlooking from this is gonna
be isn't
and in terms of the overshadowing uh
given the fact that it's not going to
have a major impact on the inhabitable
room in terms of the main salt light
source of habitat room again i don't
think that can be uh sustained in terms
of any kind in in terms of objection so
given the uh
given that point i guess it was
mentioned also it's a one last point for
me that number two could choose to
remodel yes it could it could completely
remodel for that matter it could level
it
and build an entirely new house there
but we can only deal with that which
we've got there presently we can't say
well what happens if number two
completely remodels yes it could it
could completely remodel it could indeed
could level the house and build an
entirely different house there and that
could have a completely different
relationship to to the property that
we're talking about but that's not an
argument because you can't go for it on
that basis so given those points i was
going to make those points i stand by my
initial uh
my initial argument that i i made
earlier and uh i'll wait to see what
everyone else has to say thank you
chairman thank you and encounter the
welton
thanks chair um
yeah it's not about the the the overall
size of the property uh it's about its
location with respect to number two and
i think we've we've clearly identified
that that is the key
the key issue here
um
it is
very close
now it would would become very close to
number two and the concern is this
proposed north elevation it's very blank
i mean i think this is one of those
situations where we we're not helped by
the fact that we we're seeing this on on
drawing plans if we were able to see a
you know to see a more of a life-like
render then perhaps we might actually go
oh
we you know maybe it doesn't actually
look so bad in in in 3d i know i've
certainly been influenced by 3d plans
in the past but what i'm seeing on the
paper here is not
you know
it's not attractive it's overbearing you
know in relation to the garden of number
two and this and and the side window
which is
where the kitchen is so it's obviously
going to be regularly used
um and that is my
that's my concern with this proposal if
you could pick up the whole development
and move it over in the plot a bit
you know they've got a large plot
they've chosen to
build towards the neighbors rather than
you know more in the other direction if
they i mean
possibly which could have been a
possibility
um
and i i
so i i am concerned with with this north
elevation i'm very
you know been
i've been moved by councillor dagnall's
comments and some of the other the
comments um
in that direction um i would also say
that the way that this has been
presented and the uh and
and the the way it has been
the speeches in favor you know in terms
of talking about how they need to expand
their property i really don't find these
kind of things helpful i mean
there is always the option of moving
house you know which is what a lot of
people do um you know when they need a
bigger property so there is always an
option there so i don't find that a
convincing justification for you know
for for a very very large scheme like
this um but i'll listen to any further
comments thank
[Music]
you thank you i think
if members
could try and restrict comments
um
to planning grounds i'm conscious we're
talking about somebody's um
property here and it
will be deeply personal to the applicant
um
counselor diagonal i think you indicated
you wanted to come back into this i
really just wanted to ask a question if
that's okay um
um relating to what council chalking
said about parking
um
do you imply when you suggest that
there's parking available on the street
that is outside that property
there is pop there's the zone street
parking there is on street parking i
appreciate that but are you suggesting
that it would be outside that property
well
i suppose what we're saying is there's
parking in the locality we don't say
they could park outside their property
but there's parking in the locality
right it's just that from my point of
view they would struggle to park in
front of their own property unless they
blocked one of their own drives because
of the 10 meter restriction of parking
against the junction but if you're
suggesting that there is parking within
the location and that they would be able
to perhaps outside somebody else's
property then i'll take your point thank
you
counselor thomas
thank you just to clear up a couple of
points uh and move my uh proposal
forward with some uh
basis um
compliance is remodeled we we
uh give planning permission on the basis
that somebody might remodel a house or
that somebody's got a a rather large box
as we said it uh which is a lot further
away but on the proposal of
recommending roof
refuse planning mission it's on the base
of overshadowing
loss of immunity both residential
environmental and visual
massing of property and proximity and
scale to number two
chilton drive now the reason that that's
the reasons for me i uh proposing we
refuse planning permission thank you
sorry can you clarify what you mean by
environmental
sunlight into the back garden uh there
would be none
it would be permanently in shade
[Music]
can i just um draw members attention to
the fact that a daylight and sunlight
assessment has been submitted
so if we were to refuse on loss of
sunlight and daylight we
because we've got a report that says it
it would be it would meet the british
standard we would be um at risk there
just to
overshadow it i mean um the sense of
overbearing enclosure is more of a
judgment call but i'm just drawing your
attention to that is that an officer um
sunlight um
analysis no that was submitted by the
applicant we don't do um
we don't produce our own um technical
reports on that we make a judgment call
okay in that case i'll remove the
sunlight from
the objection on that
first of all i
uh my next door my my colleague it is
really
it's not fair to say to
say just to move the house because there
are many emotional things involved with
the family
and number two i can't see any
they should be strong we need to
identify the harm to the community as
well so which is only one
only one neighbor is going to be
affected and i don't think since there
is any
strong reason to refuse this
this is what i want to say
understood thank you councillor um i
think that we've had quite a lengthy
discussion about this application now
just to clarify where we're up to it's
been proposed by councillor thomas and
seconded by councillor dagnol that um
permission be refused contrary to
officer recommendation
has also been a motion proposed by
councillor bunting that permission be
granted
um is there anyone who wants to make a
point that hasn't been made in the
discussion
no i suggest we move to the vote then
content with the
reasons have been expressed to justify
can i just clarify that i've got picked
up the points that are raised so
massing scale
proximity to number two and the impact
on the amenity of number two and number
43.
excuse me jarrod councillor bunting's
proposed uh been seconded
okay we'll take that to the vote then um
members who are
supporting the motion to refuse
permission can indicate now
okay and those
um not supporting the motion to refuse
can indicate
okay i made that seven to four
um so that motion is carried um
permission for the development is
refused
um
now turn to application 104 821
stratford grammar school which can be
found on page 35 of your committee
report
oh
back
is
um
apologies we're actually going to turn
to application 104 799
hail country club which can be found on
page 10 of the committee report
okay
so
so
foreign
okay
application 104 799 heyo country club
and before we hear from speakers the
application is going to be introduced by
ms milner
ready
okay
so the next application is the hail
country club located on the northern
side of clay lane um which is where the
access is from um parking is the north
side of the clubhouse and the site is
located within the
greenbelt the application relates to
extensions to the existing clubhouse
together with new facilities and
including extending and improving the
existing external terrace extensions to
the car park and
reconfiguration of the car parking
layout along with associated landscaping
um the application is reported to
planning committee because more than six
objections have been received and main
concerns relate to residential amenity
highways and ecology
in relation to development within the
green belt all elements of the proposal
are to considered to fall within the
appropriate development test as set out
within the mppf the proposal is not
considered to represent a
disproportionate addition to the
existing building and therefore is not
considered to harm the openness of the
green belt
the proposed building extensions are
considered to be an appropriate scale
design and materials in relation to the
existing building and the proposed new
buildings within the terrace are
considered to be in keeping in character
and scale
and
i would draw members attention to the
comments on the existing section 106
with
relating to the club and which
there are some current issues with we
have received council advice on this and
it has been clear to us from our legal
advice that any outstanding issues with
that section 106 do not impact on the
proposal before members currently this
is to be considered on its individual
merits therefore subject to the
conditions as set out in the report we
do recommend approval
thank you
thank you ms milner um do you have a
speaker in favor of the application kt
daniels
hi mrs daniels thanks for joining us if
you can just make sure that microphone's
on before you
start your contribution you've got three
minutes to speak and if you want over
time i'll just ask you to wrap up thank
you very much
thank you is that fun yeah perfect
thank you good evening councillors my
name is katie daniels of you in kelly
property solutions and we are the
planning consultants working on this
project
the applicant thd acquired hill country
club in 2016 as part of their investment
into infrastructure to support the
growth and durability
of their core online health and beauty
businesses
since acquiring the site thd have been
made aware that there are outstanding
section 106 obligations relating to the
club which were not fulfilled by the
previous owners and thd are currently in
discussion with your officers regarding
the regularization of these issues
as noted within your offices report and
as mentioned by ms milner these
outstanding obligations should not have
a bearing on the current application
which needs to be considered and
determined as a standalone application
and on its own merits against local and
national policy
turning to the proposed development the
application seeks permission for
amendments to the existing access road
and extension of the parking area
a small extension to the existing
building
and a refurbishment of the existing
terrace located to the south of the
building including the erection of a new
pavilion pergola servery and toilet
facilities
whilst the parking areas are proposed to
be extended due to reconfiguration with
the access and re-lining of the spaces
to ensure the widths of the parking
spaces are more generous the number of
spaces available on the site will reduce
from 252 to 220
this reconfiguration however will ensure
all parking spaces provided can be
utilized by members which is not the
case at the moment with regards to the
extension of the existing building this
is limited to a small single-story
extension which represents an increase
in floor space of approximately 12
percent
this extension will allow the internal
reconfiguration of the ground floor
space to provide refurbished facilities
as outlined within your office's report
the proposed development is considered
acceptable in greenbelt policy terms and
the proposals will not have a greater
impact on the openness of the green belt
with regards to other development
management policies the office's report
confirms the proposal will not have a
detrimental impact on the visual
immunity of the area nor the surrounding
residential properties and a number of
conditions have been proposed to ensure
the refurbished terrorist area is used
appropriately
to conclude the proposed development
complies with local and national policy
requirements and there are no technical
reasons which would preclude the grant
of planning permission
it should also be recognised that hail
country club makes a significant
contribution to trafford's leisure and
health economy and the proposed works
once complete will improve the vitality
and functionality of the club ensuring
it continues to attract and retain
members and in turn support the local
economy through current and future job
creation
thank you chair i do hope the committee
is able to support the officer's
recommendation for approval today
thank you ms daniels um are there any
members looking to counsel thomas to
open the discussion thank you
i have fun memories of this site from
way back when it was british airways
uh played football on the carpet there
um i'm
95 in favor of this application i think
the uh the south terrace is quite
exciting
my only concern and going through the uh
the papers and having visited
the extension to the car park the car
park when i was there to me the the
spacing was adequate
uh but i'm concerned about the trees and
within the papers there's an advert
there's a representation that there
could possibly
be an adverse impact on
bats and wildlife in the area and i
would assume it's by the removal of the
trees to the uh
very end of the car park there is some
i don't know what the call but it's like
a hard standing between the car park
existing car parking the trees where i
would imagine that it's an overflow car
park i think that part of it works okay
as and and would work okay as it is but
generally i'm very much in favor
of what is uh what looks an excellent
club with good facilities and only
improving i think it'd be good to have
in traffic
thank you counselor morgan
um thank you chair um
i know this well as it's in in my ward
and despite being called the hill
country club is definitely in the
timberly part of um of my ward but um
certainly has the boden rugby club um um
next to it um i i mean a lot of there's
been a number of objections i'm sure
members have seen but that relates to
prior to the um removal of the
amendments to the now withdrawn scheme
and i think all of the all of the issues
are covered the one item i would raise
is highways there was recently sadly a
death just um
up the road at the wellfield
lane junction
and it is a very
difficult road um
which is very busy to honest with you
for the the traffic from altering them
typically um um and sail up to the
airport um and
um
it's a very tight country lane for for
trafford particularly um but i don't
think that this will significantly
change the the highways um usage and i i
agree with council thomas i think it's
really um positive developments um
um i think the um additions would have
been more controversial and required
further debate um but i think i'm more
than happy to thank cancer thomas
proposed i'm i'm more than happy to
propose that we um accept granting this
um application thank you
would you second hit that motion
counselor yeah happy second chef thank
you um and councillor walter
yes i'm i'm
of the same mind as the previous
speakers but i would like to raise um
you know raise the issue of the of the
sector what section 18106 money i mean
there are there's a whole lot of
conditions at the end of this and uh you
know what's the point of having
conditions if you know and
if
that kind of thing is not is not going
to be met i'm really glad that there's a
um
a travel plan
in the conditions and um with the aim
and objective of reducing car travel to
and from the site
because that is a major issue it may be
a major contributor to the local economy
but it's also a major contribution to
local congestion and traffic
and that's
really really really needs dealing with
so um but i will be supporting it you
know
with that caveat thank you
thank you counselor and i agree with
them sentiment you've expressed around
the 106 contributions and as we've heard
it's not relevant to the decision we'll
make tonight but i think the message can
still be articulated that um that that
sort of behavior from developers won't
be tolerated by uh this authority moving
forward um councillor hartley i think
you suggested you had a question
thank you chair uh yeah just to just to
echo those comments about the
section 106 agreement with the previous
owner and also some other points so that
people have made i think um
i have no objections to application i
think
in some ways you know the recladding
and some of the redevelopment probably
will improve the appearance and
the extensions are modest i think aren't
a 12 extension in floor space so i don't
think it has any any uh noticeable
impact on on the green belt i had uh one
question about one of the conditions uh
which
was
had it a moment ago oh here we go um
so um
paragraph 79
the
[Music]
report says that um it's necessary to
provide an element of specific green
infrastructure
a landscaping condition will be attached
to make specific reference to the need
to provide additional trees on site as
part of the landscaping proposals
so i think that's that's probably
particular importance given what we know
about
the failure to comply with the section
106 agreement by the
previous owner which was to plant 114
trees i think
um but the the relevant condition is
condition seven which
refers to the um
the submission of the
landscaping plan
it doesn't make a specific reference to
the need for additional trees but
i'm assuming that
part of the process of improving the
landscaping plan will be to ensure that
it does
uh include additional trees if that did
that make sense yeah
it does and
we can
kind of add a line in to be specific
about the trees to say including details
of replacement trees to be to be you
know for the avoidance of doubt we can
easily add that in that's not a problem
yeah i think
that would preferable for my part of you
given the you know the impacts from the
previous uh issues yeah thank you
i was just gonna to know but councillor
hartley did cover it the breach of the
the section 106 was by the previous
owner the current owner as soon as it we
did highlight it to them they have
sought to engage with us over those
issues
thank you thanks um
council the chalking
all right thank you um
just just a quick one i i i'm in support
of this uh application i don't really
have
um
much to say on it as it did make me
laugh councillor welton went about the
um the travel plan because anybody um
if you know the users on the site the
last thing they're going to be doing is
wanting to cycle there or to uh to get
out their cars um
so while i welcome the sentiments uh
it's it's probably never going to happen
and although on that list applicants is
here they can take away that um
access for bikes to the site is pretty
poor and that does need to be addressed
so i i will say that just to clarify
something on the recommendations if i
can number 14 and i'm assuming it's a
licensing thing but just
um there'll be no use of the south
terrace by
customers
after 11 o'clock at night
i'm assuming that's a license thing
because the club's only open until 10
and one of the concerns of residence is
that it it does disturb them at night so
could just clarify i think we that we've
carried that over from the previous
permission
so
it would be kind of unreasonable to
think to to go lower so that's why we
just added it on for no that's right
it's just a query thank you
thank you thank you
i think it will be i'm very fully agreed
to my colleague
consu sam
uh it will be a fantastic addition in
that area and
according to the thesis recommendations
it is development is on the green belt
and
and it is not affecting an openness
and but i think i fully
support this application
thank you
thank you i think i'm hearing sort of
unilaterally of opinion here um are
there any members
looking to make any additional points
that haven't been raised
no okay if it has been proposed in a
second did the permission for this
development be granted in line with
officer recommendation uh we moved to
the vote members happy to support that
motion can indicate now
cam make that unanimous decision and
that permission is granted um we'll now
turn to application 106 136
but no we won't
we'll be going
to
application 104 821 stratford grammar
school which is on page 35 of the
committee report
um this application will be introduced
by ms milner
this application relates to the proposed
installation of solar panels on the roof
of stratford grammar school which runs
onto granby way in stratford the
application has been reported to the
planning committee because the applicant
is traffic council and we have received
objections
the proposed solar panels would be
located to the roof of the main school
building in total 288 solar panels would
be installed which would cover an area
of approximately 724 square meters
letters of representation have been
received before properties raising
design and amenity concerns in regards
to the solar panels heat pumps and other
mappers regarding accuracy of
information within the application form
the proposed heat pumps have now been
removed from the application and are no
longer um for consideration
um it is considered that the solar
panels would be acceptable in terms of
design and visual amenity and would have
no unacceptable impacts on residential
amenity of neighbouring properties for
the avoidance of doubt i wish to clarify
that as the planning department were
aware that the applicant was the council
the application is being determined in
accordance with our constitution being
that as
one or more objection has been received
it is before planning committee for
consideration
therefore we recommend approval thank
you
thank you um
don't have any speakers present speaker
either again store in favor of the
application so we'll open the discussion
council minister indicating
we're expediating i think
um i'll propose that we support this i i
love i'm glad the school was wanting to
put so panels all over the roof just
like my house thank you
thank you councillor tag now
i agree with council ministers live
secondary proposal we accept it
just to echo that is a welcome
development thank you
thank you councillor bunting
i have a sense of deja vu chairman
i get the feeling we're probably going
to receive one of these for every school
in the boa um that yeah they'll be the
usual objections yes i agree
from a aesthetics point of view they
look hideous but
as i said last the last committee
meeting when we got two and
uh two of these you know that's maybe a
challenge for the greens to
come up with a solar panel that doesn't
look ugly uh whether they'll ever
succeed
i wouldn't put too much money on that
chances of getting it passed uh in terms
of any refusal well yeah it'll get this
is gonna go through obviously but
they've got to spend the money from the
green levy somehow so uh this is the
solution uh yeah the advantages people
can argue i suggest maybe the main one
is virtue signaling but
that's as it is uh but i'm not raising
any objection because i in terms of
proposals because i know there's little
or no point thank you chairman thank you
councillor welton
yeah having had a look through the
objections to this i don't think
anybody's really actually objecting to
the solar panels themselves there's
various issues with the with the way
that it's been done there seems to be
some bad feeling also left over from
previous applications from
from the school but that's obviously
that's not a relevant concern i did want
to ask a question
um about the application form and
section um section eight i just wanted
to check that that is is that filled in
correctly
um
is the says the authority employee or
member
and it says that they are not a member
of
staff of the authority
uh on there and i wondered if they were
question eight is there for us to
recognize if the applicant is a
officer of the council that's usually
when it's a personal application
here we are fully aware
that the applicant's the council
so whether they ticked yes in that box
or not the resulting um point would be
we'd be here today at planning committee
so they haven't ticked they are
a an employee of the council
not out of trying to mislead us just
because it is interpreted that that was
for personal rather than professional
reasons um
but we have um discussed this with legal
and nobody is prejudiced because
the application is before members
sure thank you very much just one thing
that was raised in the objection so i
thought we were good to clarify thank
you
okay thank you um it has been proposed
and seconded that um this application be
granted permission in line with officer
recommendation it's not anyone who wants
to make any additional 0.7 billion
oh okay yeah we'll turn to the vote then
if members happy to support that motion
can indicate now
and those not happy to support the
motion can indicate
thank you
all right thank you very much
that application is approved
um
um i'm now turned to application 106 136
82 hem croft road
in timperley which can be found on page
84 of the committee report
okay so application 106 136 82 ham cross
road and this application is going to be
introduced by miz milner
this application relates to a two-story
end of terrace property located on the
south side of hemcrop road within
timperley
planning permission is sought for the
erection of a part single part two-story
rare extension and a single-story front
extension
the application has been reported to
planning committee due to smaller
sorry due to more than six or more
objections being received objections
have raised concerns about the levels of
overshadowing and overlooking that the
extension would create in addition
concerns have been raised about parking
and the damage and destruction that were
declared from
construction of the extension
amendments have been sought through the
application process to reduce the rear
projection and the height of the rear
extensions
the proposed extension is now considered
to be an appropriate design
and is not considered to result in harm
to the amenity of neighbouring
properties especially given the context
of the site and therefore subject to the
conditions recommended in your report
we do recommend approval
thank you um
did have a speaker against sharon ackley
who has provided a statement which will
not be without by ms coley
thank you chair
um this is a statement on behalf of
sharon ackley of 78 hemp croft road in
timpani
the amended plans will still cause the
same problems as stated in my previous
email overshadowing overlooking visual
intrusion noise and disturbance
air pollution from steel saws cement
mixers excavators diggers also the
extension will overlook my garden cause
a significant loss of light to windows
the size position and design of the
extension are all key factors of why i
don't want this extension to go ahead
this is just too big and take far too
long not to mention having to wash the
debris from my car every day i can also
see from the plans the veranda looks to
have doubled in size
due to the time and noise and dust it
took to erect a perimeter fence around
this property and the height of the
fence which now reduces the view of
brook's drive drove me insane soaring
hammering banging all day every day for
weeks and weeks not to mention the
trucks coming and going cut down hedges
still left on the roadside weeks after
the fence fence was finished which is
still there today i thought this was bad
enough until i received this letter the
dust and noise pollution from saw cement
mixers carpenters roofers etc will be
ongoing for far too long on an extension
of this size also i can see from the
plans there will be a balcony added to
the building which will also looks like
it will overlook my garden privacy and
again we'll obscure more of the view of
brooks drive i also have great concerns
about losing my privacy in my back
garden as i will be overlooked brooks
drive as you will know is a well-used
wildlife conservation and bridal path
for horses which can easily be spooked
by noise which can result in injury to
the rider and all the horse these are my
reasons to reject the plans to go ahead
if the house buyer needed a house of the
size maybe he should have looked in the
bowdoin area thank you
thank you ms coley and there is a
speaker in favor of the application
david or mister
hi mr roman thank you for joining us and
you've got three minutes to speak if you
can just make sure that the microphones
on it should sort of be illuminated
yeah wonderful okay thank you very much
this is an interesting application being
the end runner
of the few terrorist houses on the
broomwood estate and he also backs onto
brooklyn to brooks drive as has been
stated
there were minor in
details that needed to be sorted out
with the planning officer
to do with the boundary situation can i
say at this stage there was no balcony
at all ever envisaged on this site
it basically
the objections have just heard
basically appear to be with noise and
things like that this is no different
from anywhere else and obviously the
restricts restrictions on
weekend work etc etc but we work
closely with the planning officer
dealing with it and uh
but for the covid uh situation would
have been probably at you a lot earlier
to to make your decision uh we're quite
happy with with the application as it
stands it has been amended to what the
planners require and we're happy with
that thank you very much
thank you mr misha any members that
counselor thomas opened the discussion
thanks sure um
been to the site again uh this weekend
um
whilst it is a large
extension
uh and
sadly i think uh as alluded to in the uh
representation by the opponents of the
uh
planning application too many people are
tending to
build houses out rather than going on
book the property ladder i think wrong
i said
i can't see any reason why
we object to this this application going
through it's an
adequate distance from
any of the neighbors that may possibly
be affected
by uh the extension um
[Music]
whether i i would have that myself
i don't know if it's irrespective so i'm
happy to propose we
uh
pass and agree with the officer
recommendation
thank you um councilman morgan
um thanks chair i'm a slightly gate from
council thomas i can understand the
objections there is a it is a quite big
expansion of what's currently there um
and
um
the
the the building on the first floor
to a slight extent will overlook the
neighbor um
i i would
caveat one of the points has been raised
about the
the view to books books drive actually
the angle is it's not effectively an
east west house it's slightly beers to
the north um so actually that reduces
the impact the the um the
um extension will have and particularly
the fact there's a slight deviation in
the upstairs um um
um
extension um but i can't i i i don't
think they're any the the size of the
past is quite substantial as is the
neighbors um and i do think there's um
adequate parking um provision on the
house as it is um so i'm more than happy
to um i said that more than happy to
second councillor thomas's appraisal
that we accept this um um proposal thank
you
thank you um councillor bunting
yes thank you chairman um echo obviously
the view is already expressed by their
two previous speakers i can't see any
substantive reasons to um as to why they
should be refused to be able
uh as as has already been pointed out
just one thing obviously to make clear
i'm sure obviously officers already
just for public record that we can't
take into account the noise that will be
caused while you're building something
that's not something that planning can
do obviously if you did that any
application could be if you deemed
unacceptable because you're going to
disturb your neighbors when you build it
it's not possible to build buildings uh
silently uh it simply uh simply isn't so
i'm afraid that's not something that we
can take into account and also obviously
mentioned and things like views and all
the rest of it again there is no right
to review so i can uh i can i can't see
any substantive
substantive reason to refuse the
application i'm on that reason chairman
i'll be voting in favor of officer
recommendation thank you chairman
thank you i'm councillor hartley
uh thank you chad just just on the point
i mean i i can't see any reason to to
refuse the application uh i think
the residential immunity
objections are all well addressed in the
report
a lot of the concerns do seem to be
around the noise and the mess and the
construction work that's already
occurred on site and uh
appreciate what councilor bunting says
that's not a that's not a planning
matter although it is
is sometimes when we have a construction
management plan but i'm assuming that
that would be disproportionate on an
application
uh like this um so i suppose my question
is in the absence of that um
i do have some sympathy with the
residents about the disruption that's
being caused by
um the construction that always what is
what was their remedy for that would it
be to contact environmental health to
complain about the noise and the hours
of work et cetera yeah okay thank you
counselor
particularly the timings when the
structure management comes sometimes it
comes too early in the morning and then
we got a lot of
noise created so make sure that the
timing should be
acceptable to the neighbors
okay so it's been proposed and seconded
that um permission for this application
be granted in line with officer
recommendation i can't see any of the
members indicating they'd like to
contribute so turn to the voter members
uh happy to support the motion can
indicate now
okay make that decision unanimous and
that commission is granted and we'll now
turn to application 104 761
sale high school which can be found on
page one of the committee report
this application is going to be
introduced by ms milner
thank you chair
this application proposes to install
solar panels on the roof of sale high
school which runs onto norris road in
sale the application has been reported
to planning committee because the
applicant is traffic council and
objections have been received contrary
to officer recommendation
it's proposed to locate the solar panels
on the sports hall there would be 288
covering an area of 520 square meters
a letter of representation has been
received from um one address and raising
concerns of amenity safety and
disturbance and concerns regarding the
installation of the solar panels um it's
considered that given the limited
projection above the web roof level the
proposed solar panels would be
acceptable in terms of design and visual
amenity and would know have no
unacceptable impacts on residential
amenity given the separate date
separation distance to the nearest
residential property is approximately 50
meters therefore subject to conditions
we recommend approval
thank you ms milner council administ
indicating election
sending this to the last one i'm more
than happy to propose that we uh accept
the officer's recommendation please and
approve thank you thank you councillor
hartley
thank you chair happy to second uh
council amenities proposal that we
agreed officer recommendation uh welcome
contribution to renewable energy
generation public benefit because it's
reducing the carbon footprint of the
school
uh sports halls at the rear and it's
setting from the boundary no impact on
residential immunity
and anticipating
councillor bunting's usual refrain that
we may hear in a moment um i actually
think the solar panels will add design
interest to
the sports hawks it's otherwise a very
austere and utilitarian building so i
think it will improve the visual
immunity of that building thank you
thank you um
councillor bunting yes thank you
chairman i wasn't aware that sarcasm was
a valid defense in planning um
okay the same comments as before yeah
they are i say unfortunately so that is
the problem with solar panels there is
no way of doing it without looking
horrible uh show me a building that has
ever had solar panels look on it you
look at me think oh my god yeah in some
ways that's part of the virtue signaling
aspect of it look at me i care so much
i'm even prepared to make my house look
hideous um you know um
in terms of this one though the only
good thing about it is that it is a
significant distance away
from the uh
from the residential properties but you
still will get that glinting as the sun
catches and which is as i say a
challenge for the greens to find a way
of making solar panels look attractive
i've never seen any yet that i've
achieved it
counselor thomas
thank you chair can i can i just
recommend that uh
the aesthetics and appearance of solar
panels be a matter of opinion not for
the planning committee
councillor welton
uh i think possibly it should be for
those who
have problems with the design of solar
panels to
design some nicer looking ones
so that therefore you know so therefore
everybody would benefit from this
those of us who like the utility and
sometimes the appearance of solar panels
are quite happy at the moment thank you
thank you it's been proposed and
seconded the um permission for this
application be granted in line with
officer recommendation can't see any of
the members indicating they'd like to
contribute so turn to the vote members
happy to support that motion can
indicate now
okay members not happy to support the
motion
make that ten to one that application is
approved
and that concludes agenda item six um
applications for permission to develop
gender item 7 is urgent business haven't
been notified any ancient business and
with that we can close the meeting thank
you
[Music]
just um
if we can just
hold back for five minutes i think